but most of the people commenting on
like negative reviews on professors was
because like they just probably didn't
do the work at all times it didn't take
a turn towards like Tinder or something
like like now date my professor oh yeah
whoa I bet Anthony did a bunch of that
yep
[Music]
we kind of talked about this earlier
chat GPT
there's this professor who flunked all
his students all of them good
after a chat GPC falsely claimed that it
wrote their papers oh falsely claimed
yeah you're fine until you get caught
falsely claimed chat gbt didn't write
their paper oh good did not but then
he's using it is it so how do you use it
where's the evidence so that's the irony
in it so Texas A M University uh the
Commerce seniors who have already
graduated were denied their diplomas
because of an instructor who incorrectly
used AI software to detect ai's Chef who
can't even use it good so this is all
good
because they're preparing them for the
real world yeah it ain't always Fair
yeah in the real world sometimes you
just get [__] for no reason
[Laughter]
group of people in the real world Chad
GBC takes your job have you guys used it
it's pretty it's pretty it's pretty
effective I run a contract with it
really that's tight it saved me like 250
bucks we haven't even begun to like
fully use the power of that thing man
because it's definitely so limited
already right because isn't it like the
real one behind a paywall too like the
like the next version oh yeah yeah
depending yeah I'm sure that has way
more features because mid-journey used
to be free and now you have to pay for
it what's mid-journey that's like the
one that a lot of people use for art oh
the one that all the people are pissed
about yeah devaluating their art yeah
that sucks so this is an agriculture
Professor uh Jared mum who sent students
an email Monday informing them that he
put their homework through the
application and the AI chat bot
incorrectly determined they all used it
uh they all used it to write the
assignment the bot reported it had
written every single one of the students
papers leading mom to give them all an
incomplete grade in the course he said I
put everyone's last three assignments
through two separate times and if they
were both claimed by chat gbt you
received a zero is that what Chad gbt is
even like designed to do to like
designed to do everything to recognize
its own work you mean yeah but it
falsely claimed this you know some
students who had already walked the
stage at graduation were temporarily uh
temporarily denied their diplomas good
yeah life's gonna [__] you over welcome
to life here's
gonna happen to me I walked I went to
get my diploma and then they ran out of
paper and they're like wait a minute
there's a still a [__] GE you never
took and I was like are you [__]
kidding me imagine you didn't take
homeic it was world history it was like
so I had to uh go back to a community
college over the summer to just take one
class how did it happen though with your
schedule I don't know because once you
have isn't that the whole point of
advisors don't they kind of keep track
of that some of them suck yeah I didn't
even know I could transfer without
having it done yeah but I didn't take
that class so I had to go and [__]
take it I never picked up my diploma
really let me go find it because I feel
like if I go back to UCI they're gonna
be like yo 283 dollars for these
textbooks don't you want a little frame
things you can show your kids like hey
look dad graduated before yes you got
the transcripts though it's for the
story yeah that's not that much money
right for your diploma do you still have
the book so get your diploma please
that's a lot
um so this is a chat gbt your haircut
costs 300 yeah
that's a fancy haircut
dude I like that you sassy boy
I gave up on here
doesn't have an official feature made to
detect writings generated by AI or even
its own work and in the past has claimed
credit for original pieces including
passages from the classic novel crime
and punishment
the floodbot is known to be not very
accurate at detecting but of course
there's still an ironic conversation to
the idea like we were joking about
earlier students using chat GPT to like
get through class and then professors
also using them to like get hell yeah
dude class I wish I could be there for
that moment that the professor like got
moded hot his students you're like yes I
got every single one of them didn't you
if you could if you get the F everybody
get an F then afterwards like [__]
oh what did happen though in order to
like convince him otherwise is um
some students say they provided the
professor proof that they hadn't used
chat GPT via time stamps on Google
Documents but he initially ignored the
evidence reportedly writing I don't
grade AI [__] in the school's
grading Software System oh [__] this
guy's watched too many YouTube videos
about the dangers of AI what but the the
[__] kind of twist on this is one of
the students or one of the redditors who
was on this uh because this he even went
to the Reddit and wrote on some of this
stuff too one of the redditors took a
part of his doctoral dissertation on Pig
farming Pig forming put it in Chachi BT
to see if it had been plagiarized and
said that that was plagiarized
so then he was like all right [__] bro
he just used the same approach so chat
gbt is [__] faulty as [__] yeah but
you're also the guy who's like good
that's good because the world is faulty
yeah sometimes you go buy a pack of
batteries only three of them work damn
that's a bummer oh that would be really
messed up wait that's happened that's it
sucks yeah that's really sad Fighters
are expensive too bro sometimes you buy
things and you open it and it's burst it
on the inside
it could be a can of Coke yeah you could
buy a box full of popcorn and it's
[__] bursting inside yeah oh yeah
what about Starbursts yeah smack did
order like a expensive uh thing of
dishes and like most of them are broken
see me bursted
inside I learned through Tick Tock the
other day
the popcorn bags that little hole in the
top that's when you make it you'll hang
it over and the kernels fall out the
kernels that didn't pop wait shut the
[__] wait there's a hole is that what
that's for send me that Tick Tock bro
literally it's one of those like I was
today years old person finished with
popcorn you know they got that little
hole that you usually just smell [__]
did you know the [__] clippy clip or
maybe not for this one restaurant but
it's for the straw yeah that's old news
Bart [__] dude well I just found out
wait what's the reason for putting the
straw in there if it holds it in place
so it's not wobbling around yeah yeah
you never had a free falling straw we're
trying to chase the straw dude you're
right crazy while you're writing Big
Thunder Mountain
no I bought something from Amazon the
other day it was some dog treats for my
children came out bursting bruh
and then I was trying to [__] get a
refund through Amazon and they wouldn't
give me a refund that's sad because it's
normally supposed to be very easy yeah
yeah bro I was like what that drop it
off at Kohl's dude
I just want a refund because my my box
was bursted it really was burst had
bursitis
yeah and you couldn't eat the snacks
anymore the dot well did you try it at
least the dogs it's for the kids so the
kids can try it I'm sure they could but
it's like you know dude some dog treats
have ingredients like normal people food
your kids are probably full from eating
their own [__]
hey man hey those are my [__] kids
man watch your [__] mouth it's so
like get a breath mint for your kids
just jog my memory if things like chat
are today's generation of things that
like students have to like think about
or worry about or use or get caught for
what were things that we were doing what
were we thinking about doing
turnitinin.com yeah we had that thing we
have to type a paper and then send it to
that thing yeah yeah I feel like when
you would have to reference papers or
whatever reference other uh cite your
Source besides your sources when he
would put it in it would just be red
underlined red like constantly and you
would have to like as long as you cited
it then it's all good but like half your
paper would be [__] ready because
you're constantly citing sources or
whatever the [__] that is geez uh
besides that I remember Rate My
Professor rape my professor is pretty
cool that was my favorite but most of
the people commenting on like negative
reviews on professors was because like
they just probably didn't do the work at
all yeah they just sucked at the class
sometimes it didn't take a turn towards
like Tinder or something like like now
date my professor oh yeah whoa I bet
Anthony did a bunch of that yep
stop bursting me dude I'll burst you
right open brother
do a little burst on just like my Amazon
package I was really upset when I saw it
I was like what the [__] did this guy do
first did a move he literally just
slammed it probably because he just
punted it could have had the fragile
sticker I remember the first time
walking into a teacher supply store
when I was like maybe in my third or
fourth grade with a fudge and I was like
dude there's [__] books full of
answers in here because you see the same
book that you have key standardized
answers yeah the teacher's Edition
next level and I just [__] fill out
all my homework and you didn't get it
though right no what were you doing in
the teachers I think I was with my mom
so you're trying to buy extra homework
for me
my dad did that I used to actually
believe that the teachers created all of
those tests and quizzes I used to
believe that teachers were
dude most teachers are kind of dog [__]
though most teachers that you had grown
up they're probably not that good I had
like a handful that were like that
changed my life because they you could
tell that they gave a [__] you know what
I mean with the direct opposite
no no but the handful like like the like
most teachers a few that care yeah and
those are the ones that changed how you
thought about everything but isn't that
funny that because you had like a
handful that care it means so much
because most teachers suck most of them
do it shouldn't be that way right
shouldn't they all be like very valuable
in their own way yeah they're getting
paid so much they're phoning it in yes
that's anything right even at McDonald's
you I would expect every Big Mac to be
like every nugget yeah every every Patty
to be centered within the bun but
usually it's just like it's like a
little piece of meat flopping out the
side
[Laughter]
it was
[Music]